Complaint you six fine dude. Some Mattachine kiss, fine, dude.
TA take Kashi 69, right?
He is blaming everybody on he's blaming billboard
for, uh, to Kashi.
He's blaming a billboard for buying number ones,
which of course you can do that.
He said six credit cards bought Ariana Grandy.
Um, he, the, uh, the number ones, uh,
that it's it's her billboard. It's her it's that, that,
that's why they got the number one,
which of course that happened because why the
wouldn't people do that? People are like, it's not, by the way.
It's not Ariana Grundy's fault.
It's a Billboard's fault. But that's how you do it.
Dude,
on fire said before we turned this on the rich get richer and don't just say
blank, like that. But he did say that, uh,
I want to find this video and I can't find it. That's great on Takashi 69.
I should probably do this before I start recording,
but I won't do it like that because I want to do it the way I want to do it.
And you guys are here for me for that.
This is Instagram six, nine I'm back. And they mad. He says
just made everything up himself. Here we go. He talks about the,
so listen, I want the world to know that. Okay. So first of all,
he's wearing grandma's panties on his head. So already
what you're saying is not going to be as interesting as what the is on your
head. So that's a, uh, a huge criticism.
If you want people to think, you're interesting,
what's coming out of your mouth is interesting.
Don't wear grandma panties on your head. Okay?
They're literally silk pink panties that are just like flopped on his head.
They're not even pushed back. They're just like, it looks like he's the,
the chef from the Muppets that you can't, we,
and he's dressed all in white.
Like he showed up to paint with a grandma's panties on his chef,
from the Muppet, lost his, lost his job. No, a chef.
Whereas this is where he is.
He's the chef from the Muppets he's wearing all white and a.
Nat that looks deflated.
It looks like he ran at ideas and he's got so many jewelries and
four watches wearing a four watches because he's too too poor to get a watch
that tells different time zones. He just has one for each time zone,
a guy Atlantic, I got Pacific,
I got central and I got the other one that nobody ever talks about.
The one that Phoenix does that they go halfway to the year.
They go back and they halfway at a year to go the other way. Um,
I think I commented on this. I wrote four watches. Now you, there it is.
And somebody wrote, bro, who are you, Matt?
That's my favorite one.
What is a lot? You can buy number one on billboard.
I would do it in a more equitable.
The room by the way, six, nine. Do it in a more echo-y room.
Literally did it at, in a lobby somewhere.
Hey, what's up? You got Bob billboards.
That's a register in your head.
You can buy number ones on billboard. Now let me tell you what happened.
We had an ongoing investigation just now
[inaudible].
Having an ongoing investigation.
We was having an ongoing investigation, dude.
So it wouldn't get the part. If you auditioned for NYP de blue, sir,
we've we was having an ongoing indivi investigation.
Why can't I ever say investigation? That's all good. This dude is,
just Rosie Perez with face tattoos. That's who he is.
Rosie Perez.
We was having an ongoing investigation. Dude.
That's actually the dumbest sentence of all time. You either were having an,
having an investigation or there's an investigation that's ongoing.
You can't have had an ongoing investigation.
We was having an investigation that was going on. That's still going on.
Just so it up.
We was having an investigation that was ongoing to see if I could wear panties
on my head. And it turns out that ongoing. I could have opinions on my head
and I'm wearing panties on my head. I got full wide.
You want to know what time it is on the Atlantic? It's three o'clock.
You wonder what time it is on the Pacific that's 12. Oh wait.
Last Thursday.
Ariana was stuck with you submitted 60,000 units.
Last second with the investigation, we found this stop saying invest.
[Inaudible] dude, sit, trying to sound more legit.
You know, with the investigation, we found this
people are just commenting on this. Oh wait. Where's the.
They purchased half of those things was six credit
cards. When we asked,
where were those six credit cards linked to billboard said,
we can't disclose that information. Understand this.
They bought 30,000.
And so units with six credit cards.
I get it. He says that nine times during this thing, by the way,
six credit cards, six credit cards.
I got grandma panties on my head. Six credit cards.
We have a, we was having an ongoing investigation,
six credit courts.
Where's the thing about when he put it on.
When he put the investigation,
he talks about the Apple what's where's his stupid Instagram.
There's so many Instagrams for him to call she's six,
nine, God. You know what dude? I,
this is just, I don't understand. Oh, here he is.
He's sending it to me complaint. She's six fine. Um, yeah, he says,
that's like, when you say you were Apple, it's an Apple,
but also, you know, apples wed. Did you see that where it's like, Apple is red?
And of course it has the Apple green, but it's like saying the apples.
It's like, you see an Apple is red. And then somebody said, Apple blue,
six credit cards say idiot. Also.
How was he still alive? Like, I don't want anybody to kill anybody,
but how the is he still breathing? Dude, he snitches,
Oh, here it's Twitter. So I can fast forward it.
The Apple thing. He says, dude, here we go.
So listen, I want the world to know that where's the Apple thing.
If you want to explain to all the hardworking artists out there,
the hardworking artists that and established artists at that because there's a
lot of established artists right now that don't get number ones in how you
deduct. If there's 50 million streams right on Google,
why only count 30 million right? To late looking at an Apple, say,
I'm obviously looking at your, your red, but you're not,
but you're telling us it's not red. You got caught cheating red handed. Right?
So confusing. So confusing. It's like an Apple. You look at it at red.
You're looking at it and it's red. And if someone's saying it's not red,
it's like, you're cheating. You got caught red handed.
You're just saying red so many times just so confused.
It's like little red riding hood came up to you and said,
this Apple is like you say an Apple is red and little red riding hood is like
that. Red Apple. Now red, you got called red handed,
wearing red wigs.
It's like little red riding hood where red wings drive a Rav for robbery with
red man in it and red Fox.
And he say the apples, red apples red, but then red Fox is like the apples,
not red. And then you got caught red handed.
Cause you cheat and read. I read a book.
It's his favorite color
dude? Yes. Um,
it's like red foxes and Yvette convertible with you and you there.
And you said the Apple red. Okay. And then a red man pop in and he say, Oh,
the Apple not red anymore. And you got caught and you,
you know the Apple red and you read a book on it and you're like,
you read a book on cheating and you like, you got caught red handed.
The worst analogy of all time. Congratulations, compliancy six fine
dude. The way he, the way it has, no payoff is amazing. Uh,
Apple sometimes is most likely red. There's green apples. But just look at this,
first of all, just pick something that's always red. You know, Apple is red,
you know,
sometimes it's green show and sometimes there's in between an Apple could be
very, you know, very light green or dark green.
But most of the time we think of the Apple is red. Just say a, you know,
what's red, Rudolph's nose.
Just say what is always red? My, uh,
um, red swollen Dick was an episode of 10 minute podcasts.
Semi-mature never going to be running for president, but anyway, complaints,
you six fine, obviously, but he's probably dead by now.
I just started talking about it. But, and then Snoop dog made a warning to gosh,
he's six nine, which is great. Snoop Dogg's 90.
Last time you said something that I had, uh, uh.
Hey, Snoop dog, get better lighting for your YouTube video.
You've got $7 trillion.
He literally looks like one of those people that would do a F a E.
Why is he filmed by one of those people in almost got away with it?
Well, I just wanted the below that or whatever.
So for like muddy or it was illegal and was laundering.
But the day I got time.
Snoop dog, your 90.
Last time you said some, I had time.
Let the day I got time. Wow.
You better get the off my line, rat boy, rat boy,
you really better leave me alone. I ain't doing one. Oh. No way.
No way
gone and do your and get out of my way.
Get you the funky Dole head rainbow head dog, head.
So you leave the dog alone.
Readily the dog alone. Go find you a cat, a boy getting too far.
Away, too. Carried away with the analogy. You bet
better. Let the dog alone better go find a cat. You know,
they make me my leash. You know what I mean?
I'd be done eating a bunch of dog food, all full, you know what I mean?
Someone knock at the door and I'll stop barking. You know what I'm saying?
on the side of a couch. You know what I'm saying?
But to find yourself a cat, it got so far with it. I, you know,
I got a collar. Uh, did you lose your mind? I got full legs, man.
I haven't got two arms. I got full legs. You better not come from me.
Okay.
Hey dude, you're 60. Get it together.
You know? Uh, dude, I love it, man.
I love life. You know, you got this 22 year old. That's like, you know,
you got one I put as red, you know, Apple where you looking at an Apple is very,
I mean, some apples is green,
but you're looking at this Apple red and somebody come up to you and they like,
the Apple is not red. And then Snoop, Dogg's like, I'm a dog.
Don't come for the dog. Don't come for the dog. Y'all looking for a cat,
go get a cat because I'm the dog. I got folded legs.
I got instead of where my arms are. I got paws and legs.
With the dog. with the dog and then nice nothing. Nice.
Cool. Tourette's red boy rat boy again.
He close closer with the rat boy. Okay.
Oh. And then spans up for no reason.
God.
I would love if somebody, if like a troll like Takashi six, nine,
or these guys were trolls. Um,
well not even trolls guys who were famous for kind of doing
well, I guess he mean he makes music. I can't say does nothing,
but like guys who are trolls,
like guys who just want attention so bad will say like Takashi 69, uh,
Donald Trump.
Me. No like, uh, like these guys that just
are crying for attention. You know,
the chicks on insane or even worse.
The dudes on Instagram that are like, you know,
kicking back.
If just nobody ever paid a T like if some guy was a model, you know,
the male model is a chair. He's a, just a chair. Right? Modeling is for checks.
If you got a dude there you're a prop. You're the,
you're the chair for the girl to sit on. It doesn't matter. Okay. Yeah. Your,
your bone structure is nice, but you're really just the chair.
That guy that if he like for a guy to win to,
for him to join Instagram and then have him just be like, look,
zero, people felt like a zero followers.
Or if like Donald Trump tweeted some crazy, fantastic. And nobody said about it.
Or Takashi 69 came out of jail. And nobody was like that rap.
I'm going to kill him. If nobody gave a, that would be so detrimental to that.
But we can't, we can't not look at it.
We have to look at it because that's the train wreck that's happening.
You rubber net. You're like, huh? You got to look at it.
It's like when the Apple is red, you know, it's just such a,
it's a bummer.